you you get the impression that there
are hordes of racists sitting in the
canteen with hoods on
um waiting to go and victimize black
people and it's just not true
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today i'm delighted to say is a
retired police inspector of 30 years
chris danson welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much for having me listen
man it's so great to have you on the
show we're so excited to talk to you
there's been so much happening
this year to talk about but for anyone
who doesn't know who you are just give
us a rundown of what has been the
journey that you've had through life you
joined the police at 18
right and all the way through to now
just tell everybody who are you
how are you here what's been your
journey okay yeah so i i
was born in islington um grew up in
leighton
to um jamaican parents uh got
two brothers and a sister um very normal
background
my mum's a nurse was a nurse and my dad
worked at ford's
nothing extraordinary um at the age of
18 i i was in the sixth film i had no
idea what i wanted to do
um a guy down my uh rugby club paul
farrell he
suggested that i should consider the
police so i'd never thought about it
before i didn't grow up with any
aspirations to be a police officer
never before uh that conversation and
uh it it actually took all the boxes
what i'd like a lot of times in my life
i decided what i didn't want to do
before i decided what i wanted to do
and what i didn't want to do was sit in
an office um and i wanted to do
something that was uh
exciting or or certainly challenging and
and when i looked in more detail i
thought yeah why not have a go
and that's basically it i i looked at
the forms
i i spoke to paul um and i thought yeah
well at the time there was a big push
for
in recruitment and i thought yeah why
not i'll i'll have a go
i didn't think i would get that far if
i'm honest but
um i put the application from and um i'm
bored i i
i got um through the application system
and
at that point what they do is send the
local officer or local sergeant
around to your house to check that your
house or your family is suitable
um to have a police officer one lived
there and
and if it's a good family background
they've already done the checks
um i didn't tell my parents that i'd uh
i was
i'd been accepted i didn't want to have
that conversation because i'd already
made my mind up
um so my when when the sergeant knocked
at my door
um it might my dad was very shocked and
surprised he thought i'd been arrested
because because i was the one in the
family that's most likely to be
um arrested because that was that was
that was me um
so he was very pleasantly surprised that
uh i
i was um i'd applied for the police um
the the guy the guy came in the sergeant
came in my mum
ushered him into the front room with the
plastic seats and we would never have
been allowed to go into
um she got the bone china that we didn't
even know existed
we had a picture of the queen on one
side and a picture of jesus christ on
the other
the sergeant looked around and thought
what a wonderful family this is it
and my mum went into this jamaican
english
that she does when she's talking on the
phone um
and it was yeah i was in uh he was super
impressed and
um next year now i was in china school
yeah
but you've had quite a remarkable career
then on because you did lots of
different things
uh not not least you were a firearms
officer i think you said for eight and a
half years yes yeah
yeah that was quite a bit before then so
i
yeah so i was a um probationary in
covent garden bow street covered garden
i spent three years there i then went on
to uh
the territorial support group um in 87
which is a primary their role is riot
control
and crime you know high crime areas they
send them into high crime areas
um i did four and a half years on that
and then i went to
tottenham as a as a police constable i
spent some time on a broadway farm
team or as a as a
home bee officer basically i've got a
lot of experience there
um and then i got promoted
and i went to hackney which is a
bouldering
spent three and a half years there and
then i went to the firearms team
for eight and a half years yeah i was a
sergeant and inspector in the firearms
and you mentioned the riot part of it
we've obviously had a lot of protests
going on this year for different things
yes and this is where we came across you
because what we try and do on this show
is
talk to people who have a slightly
different take to a lot of other people
in terms of the mainstream narratives
and stuff
and during the protest and blm and stuff
like that you were talking about how
you'd been in the met for 30 years you'd
had a great career
and a lot of people were saying the
police in this country are racist and
you didn't agree with that no
i don't uh how come well uh because my
well first of all my experience
yeah so my experience over the 30 years
spanning and still my experience now
with dealing and mentoring police
officers is that
the general the vast majority of police
officers
are very good uh and good well-meaning
people
you know they yes like society it has a
minority who are
of racist racist opinions and racist
actions
but you really in this day and age you
really got to be committed and
ingenious racist to survive
really you really have to because once
of all you've got your cars the cars are
taped yeah and recording yeah you go
into a station they've got cameras and
with a recording you've got body-worn
camera every time you stop and arrest
someone it's filmed
and recorded now to be a racist in that
environment
with all the canteen with every every
supervisor and manager trained
to detect that kind of behavior and act
on it and some of them
want to find that behavior so that they
can
evidence it so that they can be promoted
you know
to have all that in place and then
still be a an active racist in a matter
you really have got to
go go some you really have it's not an
environment
that sustains uh an overt racist it
really isn't and i can say that
i've been there yeah and obviously some
people there are
bad experiences people have them and i'm
not saying it's not the local race is
not like the nhs hasn't got racists or
or you know media hasn't got racists of
course they have it's it's just
he's looking at us
you know the way you treat me from
phoenix you know but no and what i'm
saying is uh
on a serious note you really have got to
be
going some to survive in a met police
today
and be overtly racist you really have so
why do people say that then why do they
why do people say that the police are
racist i i i think
if you look at the figures it and they
and going back to the lawrence inquiry
you know certainly the mcpherson report
yeah
um that he he used this word um
uh institutional racism which has been
used to batter the police ever since
yeah and people wrongly suggest that
oh it's the the institution is that all
the people in it
are racist and that's not the fact
that's not the case
what they're saying is that the figures
don't look good you know people
are disproportionately they're saying
people are disproportionately shocked or
or not promoted
um in in the correct um you know ratios
whatever it doesn't reflect the people
that are actually in it
now you can have all kinds of
explanations of why those figures do
look bad
but i can tell you from a personal point
of view as
the individuals i have not seen that and
i was managing teams
you know on the ground actually policing
a lot of people who do make comments in
the in the media about
their experiences and police haven't
really placed as much as i have
i've managed to people and if i had seen
that kind of behavior i would have
jumped on it and got them out i know i
would not have tolerated it
i'm not saying they didn't exist but to
to put the both together institutional
racism and everyone's a racist in the
places
is wrong it's incorrect i think in my
opinion
um i've not seen evidence of of mass
you know you you get the impression that
there are hordes of racists sitting in
the canteen with hoods on
waiting to go and victimize black people
and it's just not true
in my opinion do you think part of the
problem is like you said
you know when people talk about
institutional racism they'll they'll say
you know black people especially young
black men are more likely to be stopped
and searched
yes and that causes real real problems
so the go go today yes they are more
likely to be searched and
and and they're also more likely to be
stabbed to death yes
in certainly in in inner cities yeah
so yes unfortunately when you're doing
these operations to combat
particularly knife crime murders you
have to go into those areas and
sometimes
for instance if a robbery victim gives a
description of
of the person that robbed them it's it's
some quite often
in particularly tackling tottenham that
person the assailant
is is black uh within an age range and
with a description
and because they're under stress they do
their descriptions aren't always
accurate i mean you try it
tomorrow you know someone runs up behind
you not stabs you don't have to go that
far but
just to hit you and run away and then
you told me what that person looks like
under stress so some quite often they're
they're their descriptions of inferior
but quite
quite often also they say they're
between
18 and 25 not all robbery but i'm just
saying
so when you're going into areas where
you want to stop kids
stop walking around with knives or
driving around with knives killing other
kids particularly black kids you have to
target that area
now in my experience of dealing with
with actual complaints
as an inspector and i have dealt with in
the processional standards
the complaint didn't come from oh he's
they only stopped me because i was black
it was because
they were rude to me or that in seville
in civil
so quite often if you do or you're
professional
and when you stop someone i got very few
complaints and i stopped a lot of black
people probably more black people than i
stopped white people
because i worked happily in tottenham i
didn't i got very few complaints
you know because it was the way i dealt
with and that's a different that's the
difficult area
because as a police officer a new
experienced police officer
you start to build up an instinct for
people
so as for instance so you stop someone
in a car one of the first things you've
done
you're taught as a as a trainee is
stopping vehicles while i was anyway in
the 80s
and i always thought well this is a bit
weird why am i down on the embankment
stopping cars
and they really the reason is because
when you stop someone
you can stop saying for instance you can
stop someone to say right sir
um your wife is really ugly or your
husband is really ugly
don't go away fair enough if you say
you're not very good driver and you've
just gone through it they want to fight
you
yeah they will not be you can't tell
people that they're bad drivers or
they've
they've done something wrong that's one
of the things that so you learn very
quickly how to
negotiate and talk uh to people
without it turning into a big fight um
and and vehicle stops quite often are
quite
uh confrontational or they'd lead into
confrontation
because people just don't want to be
told um that they are
did they transgressed or broke a law
they don't want to be told that
so but also when you come on to stopping
people you you
if someone's got something to hide quite
often
quite often not saying always quite
often they will get very aggressive
and they'll start throwing uh you know
all kinds of
allocations hoping that you'll run away
but as an experienced officer you know
what hold on a minute why is this person
so avid why is they so aggressive
now you think to yourself well should i
walk away now from this confrontation
and they've
they get away with whatever they're
getting they're trying to hide or do i
persist
and that can go badly sometimes but
experienced officers know they
quite often you must continue because if
i stop the normal member of public
they're not they're not happy about it
they're not happy about it because no
one wants their
liberty interrupted or their day
interrupted by police officers and it
feels like an
intrusion i i get that i've been stopped
myself you know
a few times and i can get that but
quite often if it goes into a
confrontation you're really rude or
you're really aggressive
that police officer starts to think well
what have you got to hide and they
they start pressing a little bit more
because what have you got to do are you
you might not be i didn't have you just
be angry you know you're just not like
the fact that your day's been spoiled
that's fine i get that
but career criminals will throw those
distractions at you
and you have to we try you know when
you're in training you you you you're
trained
to look for that kind of thing so why
are they trying to put you off the
center
what are they doing why are they are you
now going to walk away and say well you
won
okay fair enough and they'll go away
with whatever they've got sometimes they
can
so that's a really difficult area of
policing stopping people
really difficult area and it's only
experience really that makes you better
at it
i don't know anyone who looks at a car
coming towards them and knows
what that occupant the color of that
occupant until they right up on you
what you see first is the lights out or
they're on the wrong side of the road
or their registration has come up as no
insurance
or that that registration has been put
up in
in a thing but you don't say oh oh
50 yards down the road there's a black
guy dropping driving that car i'll stop
it
because you can't see them quite often
um
so yeah stop and search is a really
contentious uh
area of policing but you become better
at it the more experienced you are
and you know how to gauge that person
it's a very difficult vote but
in the minority of people it is the
minority of people you stop
are doing it for are getting aggressive
for a reason they're throwing
you off the stent for a reason uh and
and you have to as a police officer
a representative of the public by the
way you think do
are you doing that the public favor by
letting them walk away
and chris what do you say to those
people who say i think it's only three
percent
is the stat that's often used three
percent of these
stop and searches lead to an arrest it's
not an effective tactic and it just
antagonizes
black communities and other communities
as well listen i
uh three percent yeah i i listen to
people in
in in the public domain talking about it
and quite often
they have no idea that or even the
people who are ex-police officers who
didn't use the tactic quite often
because a police officer an active
police or an operational police officer
knows it's not about
or it's not always about finding a gun
or
finding a big bag of drugs it sometimes
disrupting that gag or not that everyone
who you stop is a gang member because
they're not
but disrupting that person's movement of
encouraged weapons so they're not
confident in walking around because
quite often
if you work in an area and you know the
people you see you're stopping
known gang members and known criminals
yeah
and in the old days you you weren't just
you weren't searching you don't have to
start them you just know what they were
in where they are that day at that point
of their day it's not all about
finding loot stop and search is
different you have to have reasonable
grounds that's a little bit different
but stop and talk
yeah is something else yeah because when
you've gotten the known gang members
walking around confidently
with weapons they're not always going to
stab someone but
they may do when they come into a
compensation your job is to stop them
doing being confident walking around
with those those weapons um and that's
difficult because innocent people get
stopped
and innocent people get caught up in
that that that war
you know so to speak but rather like
going on to an airplane
most people are not bringing anything
onto the airplane one of the reasons
they're not taking their
their personal use drugs or or their gun
or whatever
is because they're going to get searched
yeah they're going to get searched
i don't mind getting search going onto a
plane because i know that the guy next
to me
or the woman next to me hasn't got
semtex in her bag
yeah because i i feel safer it's not all
about the success rate of stop and
search it's what it's
the effect it has on the mind of those
criminals
so what we're really talking about is
preventative policies it is preventative
in a lot of ways
and but people wrongly look at that
three percent say well it's unsuccessful
it's it's obviously unsuccessful which
is not we need to do something else what
else what is the option
if you say for instance i'm not going to
stop anyone in hackney
or or more specifically no black people
no black person is going to be stopped
in acne for the next week
yeah vast majority of people just go
along their business
no problem but there will be a hardened
core of thinking wow this is great
i can now travel left right and center
with my gun my
my knife my whatever and i can go and do
what i have to do
it's really difficult there's no
straight straight answer
but it is one of the tools that has to
be used
unfortunately particularly in high crime
areas where there are murders
and stabbings you know i think 14 out of
the 15 stabbings
of the kids who have killed this year
were were murdered by stabbing
you know and and quite often they were
gang members not always
sometimes there were just people in the
wrong place but all the time there were
people
walking around with them you know it was
nice quite confidently
walking around with a knife i've been
shocked with some of the weapons that
i've found on people
shocked so yes the vast majority of
people
are innocent vast majority of people
have got no weapons or nothing and and
and you have to pat them down and say
really sorry that you've been
inconvenienced and that your day has
been spoiled but unfortunately the
reason i'm doing this is because
the crime in this area has gone up and
stabbings and we are trying to combat it
which brings me on to the other point
that people often make about stop and
search which is
okay look i hear you chris you're an
experienced police officer i understand
we need to do preventive policing
but why do black and brown people get
stopped a lot more
than white people i can't give that
answer because i i just think
in the particular areas like hackney and
tottenham and peckham and brixton in
particular
where we're victims of crime so
uh are um are pointing out that the
people that they who robbed them are are
black or asian
or particularly the victims of
murders and stabbings are that the
people who
perpetrated that crime are black you
have to go after those particular areas
and unfortunately when you put a tsg
that i was a member of
um into an area of high crime they're
going to have to stop
people who fit that that bill and
sadly and it is sad that those high
crime areas quite often involve um
immigrants or black people and it is sad
because there's so many good most people
are just going on they don't
i i've got two boys and they're black
kids yeah obviously
um and one of them got stopped uh got um
robbed at knife point
broad daylight yeah and i just wanted
that guy arrested he was arrested it was
pointing there and he was in he was
punished
but he was quite confidently walking
around him and his mates in north london
with knives and
if someone had said you know the police
were out in that area that
you know before stopping lots of people
um
for for knives to prevent this kind of
thing i would have been quite happy with
it i don't want my kids stabbed
and the black community has got as much
um
uh you know of uh interest in
not getting their kids hurt you know in
those areas
so yes they it's in their interest
or in in the black community interest to
support the police i would say
and certainly help the police so that
their kids aren't murdered and and
stabbed and robbed
because quite often they are victims of
crime disproportionately victims
not a lot of people like that stat you
know
that they are disproportionately victims
of crime so
just to clarify basically what you're
saying is you're targeting
those communities because that's where
there's more victims they don't target
can be they only target
you know what i mean communities we're
areas where there are high crimes you're
going into places where a lot of crime
is being committed
that's right and if if the if there's a
kid being stabbed and he happens
and the assailant has to be black
unfortunately yeah
you know this is this is the sad thing
they're letting the community their
community down i
i've black community and i feel
desperately sad for
i i've dealt with kids that are dying
i've had
i've had a child in my arms dying you
know i've had i've gone to the house
to tell parents that their kid's been
killed
i've been to her i've knocked on a door
on in tottenham
at the same time uh as uh as that purse
that that child
was going to turn up for dinner you know
at the same their mother looked straight
at me and fainted
yeah because she knew exactly what i was
going to say the daughter
just you know skipped away says we
thought it was her brother and he'd been
and i
was i had to go in when you're there
telling those parents
you know that their child has died or
has been murdered it's
awful and they're the people like damien
lola taylor's
father he he he he says there should be
more stop and search
there should be more stuff to search but
in a more he as he says humane way
yeah that goes down to training over the
individual maybe supervising
he stopped if you can there's
supervisors but
it's not retracting it it's not because
that small percentage who do
commit crime will love it they will love
it and they're the only people who are
benefiting them by the way
you know if you stop stop and search or
reduce stop and search
the only people are going to benefit
those criminals that small percentage
who are just rubbing their hands saying
now i can walk i can go from one street
to another
with a gun and a knife without getting
stopped or if i do i'll just kick off
you know so that's that's and that's a
sad
side effect of of crime in the in in
london some in a lot of crime
say for instance burglaries you go home
you find your house
burgled no one knows what that person
looks like generally
sometimes something a neighbor would say
oh i did see someone climb out the
window or whatever
or or potato or car theft no one
actually sees you saying quite often
robbery if someone is up against you you
know they'll give a
say and sadly in in like tottenham and
hackney a lot of the
a lot of the assailants are black as a
sad fact
so innocent people get caught up in that
crime or or the the police operation and
it's sad
it's sad but after i say quite often
nothing comes with that it's because the
way it's dealt with the stop how that
stops dealt with
and like i say you have to you have to
weigh up against why is this person
getting aggressive with me now
where'd you go do you go down and walk
away or do you have to deal with this
and it looks really bad i know i've been
in those situations when someone's
shouting and screaming at you
and the people now they've got their
phones out and you're
you're there you've got your body i'll
come on
am i going to press this is he really is
this person trying to
throw me off the scent oh you know what
i'll walk away because that's what
members of public always want you to do
leave them alone they have no idea what
they've done
or what they're concealing but they want
you to leave them alone so
quite often people do constantine
how do you like your things printed big
like my ego and that's why you should
use
print it big 3d what they actually do is
help you print
tabletop gaming pieces short run
manufacturing parts
and even statues from your favorite
movies and tv shows so you can get
ned stark without his head on they also
make
cosplay costumes car parts and weapons
but not real ones obviously and the
wonderful people that they are they also
make
free prosthetics for kids what virtue
signalers
on top of that they also do individual
pieces
prototypes and short run manufactured
parts
do you know what any of that means not a
clue printer big
3d are offering our fans a massive
discount you get 20
off with our code which is of course
trigger pod all you need to do is go to
the website
www dot print it big
3d dot com that's www.printitbig3d.com
i'm going to get francis a new weapon i
like weapons
so i guess the question that i want to
ask chris is
we've been talking about stop and search
yes about the divisions that it causes
and
you know that's perfectly logical so how
do we heal
the this rift between these communities
and the police and the metropolitan
police in particular
okay i think we have to
uh actually put into context
the rift for instance now the rift is
gauged by what
i don't know is survey customer survey
the the satisfaction surveys maybe yeah
black people aren't as much confidence
in the in the police yes okay
we'll get that but i know a lot of black
people who who have no problem with the
police
yeah but i see the people who are so
called representative of the black
community up there all the time
talking about the rift good place well
i don't think it's as big as people
think yeah
there's many many blaming black parents
who don't want their kids
um stopped yes but they certainly don't
want them stabbed to death
yeah and they do and they know that the
police are the only people are going to
be able to stop that really well one of
the best the most effective for people
to stop that
yes you have social workers and everyone
else and doing their part but the most
effective way
still is the police so i don't hear that
that rift as much as the so-called
community leaders and i say
irresponsible
mps keep muting all the time constantly
you'd think
every black person hates the police if
you watch
social media and i don't think it's true
yes there's a ah
there's a suspicion between the blacks
black people and the place like there
was in the 80s when i joined
i totally ignored it to be honest i
didn't ask i didn't care about what
people were going to think about me
being in his place i didn't
didn't didn't even consider it if i was
and i didn't consider it when i was in
because the vast majority of people
who were racist towards me were black
people yeah how do you mean
they were calling me judas and the
traitor people trying to set fire to me
at night in hell carnival
fighting oh yeah absolutely i had an mp
who's still in parliament at the moment
who called me a judas and the traitor
probably won't
i won't name her but yeah she still sits
there
and so i so you wait you're a traitor
i'm a traitor to the world
i don't know to black people police
officers absolutely why is that
i have no idea i still don't understand
it but that's a common
name you're called traitor and judas wow
yeah
because us and them it's like you know
it still it still mystifies me now and
it goes over my it towards the end of
the market it just went over my head
because it made no sense to me
and it still said to a lot of people
you're traitor and the judas
as if black people don't need to be
their community is capaced right as if
black people don't
need their houses to be safe as if black
people don't need
their kids to be safe of course they do
the police aren't the enemy
the the criminals are the enemy you know
so the trait a bit makes no sense no
sense at all and it never has done
yeah and i think there are
for instance now there's mr khan the
mayor has said that he wants a
increased percentage of
black people in the police in the met
please 40
yeah in the same breath he calls him
institutionally racist oh what a great
advert that is
yeah so yes kids join the met police
they're institutionally racist
have a great what on time
is that about and it's a lie first of
all
yeah it's a total misrepresentation of
the place
it's certainly not an advertising
campaign and it certainly won't increase
the the the percentage i just hope that
they
take as much notice of politicians as i
did in their days
none yeah listen to your own take things
take people as you find them yeah and i
and take people
listen to the positive notes from the
police because
i can tell you i had a fulfilled a a
very
varied and and rewarding career in the
police and i think it's a damn shame
that
young black kids are put off by
listening to clowns
in in the in public domain who knows
nothing about police
you talk about clowns in the public
domain obviously you're sort of talking
about politicians and i think the media
also have to take some responsibility
for who they choose to come on and talk
absolutely
they they'll keep burning oh it's
terrible the representation well you
keep telling people it's racist and you
know that representation's going to go
down
it's not going up it's not going to be
increased so with that in mind you talk
about the rift being
exaggerated i think so so what did you
make of blm
uh then not something i um i uh
i thought it was sad because i i was
there you know obviously
growing up in the 70s in a place in the
80s when we had a lot of racial
detentions and then we moved on
and we got to where we were like this
year
yes they're still issues but we were
miles mile we were doing really well i
think
you know you only look at a rave scene a
multi-colored rave scene you go to every
festival multi-colored you know
the theaters all people were doing were
mixing well
you know and then all of a sudden we're
now going to answer for the crimes of
america
you know and american police and the
segregation and all the issues that
they've got
it's not the same it's not the same
place
you know what happened to floyd was
disgusting
the man wasn't a police officer he was a
criminal you know he was criminal
dressed as a police officer
and he deserves everything he gets but
that didn't represent all the police
officers and it certainly didn't
represent british police officers
but it's certain it almost as if they
their anger was transferred here
and and wanted to relive that that that
that wedge
between they they wanted to you know
reenact it in in
in effect you know and i thought that
was sad
um black lives matter you know the
actual
the actual you know the label is is kind
of um
provocative in a way and it and it puts
a wedge in to see
people who never didn't really exist i
know people are angry about that
and they weren't they're definitely not
racist they just feel old in a minute
yes of course black lives matter and
every life matters
i know what they were trying to do
highlights the injustices
but the main injustice were in america
yes there were things there were issues
here
but to to to to try and um
to pretend that we had the same issues
as america it was wrong
i just think it was wrong i didn't agree
with it and there was a slogan being
that was bandied around that we heard a
lot which was obviously defund the
police
can you explain to people because i
think this is really important
why that is a stupid idea well it's a
stupid idea because what
what's your alternative what is the
alternative okay we defund the police we
stop giving the man
and let's face it the police have
effectively been defunded anyway
since the since um you know the the
first first financial
crisis you know they're really
struggling
anyway you know i know that i know the
pains that the senior officers
particularly crested it goes through to
get money from
from from the mayor and and government
that really
stretched anyway so are you going to
defund them now so okay what is your
what is your alternative no one's ever
given an alternative well what they say
chris some of them anyway
is uh what we mean when we say defund
the police is
uh more social workers will deal with
the causes of crime we'll
we'll give people mental health support
we'll make sure that
you know the the kids who may be growing
up in a difficult environment
get the right encouragement you know
stuff like that yeah right
so i think some of these people think
that if you did that you'd have no crime
oh yeah right okay so you yes your money
goes to social workers and people
dealing with a fallout of crime because
there'll be a lot more crime yeah
that's for sure so yes they're all part
of the team i had this conversation the
other day
um on the radio and all part of the team
really remember much you liking it the
social workers
the youth workers the police officers
it's all part of the team you take one
out one element out it doesn't work
you know and people say oh it isn't
working now but i
you know it's literally the finger in
the dam you know you take that one
element out and you'll see an outbreak
i'm pretty confident that in this
country it's not even being seriously
considered no i don't think it isn't
you're right i mean in america in some
of the places where
they have defunded a lot of the police
they've seen crime rights absolutely
you have to remember it's not the normal
person who's going to benefit
me and you aren't going to go well maybe
not but i don't know your neighbours but
you're not going to go and kill your
neighbour
if you can get away with it tomorrow
yeah yeah but some people will
yeah you know what i mean if they've if
they're less if they've got more chance
of getting away they will they will take
advantage of that
definitely so the police deter crimes
absolutely of course they do
or not just police the criminal justice
system yeah yeah
which is part of the same thing if
when you think about it what what stops
you from committing crime
you know the fact that you might get
caught is right up there
you know and then you may be punished is
another one that's right up there
yeah if if that was taken away the
normal
you know church upbringing a lot of us
have had you know you know the
ten commandments somewhere back in the
head or whatever religion that you've
got that stops you
the truth that makes you treat people
nicely might not be there
you know people might think you know
what a lot of police officers say
and i don't agree with this because my
my mother my family live in london
one week let's stop just stop and see
the fallout that's
reckless obviously yeah because we know
what the full level will be
yeah you can see that point though kind
of yes absolutely you will throw the
hands up and say you know what i know
police officers say right don't stop any
black person
in london for a week uh
and say oh just don't stop anyone in
london
not just black people and and
see what the effect is but we know what
the effects would be it's not
and it's reckless for the innocent
people that will be effective
uh just to prove a point to a few
individuals
you know so so what would you say to
these people who
you know say you know defund the police
who spread this message who say
like sadiq khan institutionally racist
what would you say to these people well
i wouldn't say anything to skeet khan
but
and slightly naive yeah yeah do you want
to spice up your life
yeah well in that case i have just the
product for you
it's screaming chimp chili sauce made
from fresh chilies they're a british
company based in durham that create
beautiful chili sauces that are vegan
friendly
gluten-free and free of the 14 main
allergens
they're for [ __ ]
joking aside they have a whole range of
flavors all the way from mild
to wild for real men i'm a real man
they've got a range of unique and
classic flavors they've got pineapple
mango and papaya chimpotli excellent
punch
and original hot sauce go to
screamingchimp.com that's
screamingchimp.com
and spice up your winter and and do you
think that
do you think it's naivety because the
reality is they don't know what it's
like
and and quite often some of the police
officers who uh
in the public i don't know what it's
like either we spend too much time in
strategy meetings and uh and meetings
doing this
you you know very quickly if they've
actually spent time
on the beat or actually doing police
work because they know the actual real
reality of it um so yeah
it you need they we used to do it we
used to do ride-alongs we used to get a
local mp
we in fact firearms i remember back at
graves in when we had a what we call the
gallery range and it's basically you put
in a room and a
scenario unfolds in front of you and
you're given a gun you don't really
particularly need
uh training but you're given a gun and
you have to make a decision
and firearms officers have to make
split-second decisions
you know and it could be and that
split-second decision
could be pulled apart for years yeah
so it's a very difficult and considering
that and how many whip and how many
armed crimes we have
and how many you know incidents of
police
shooting a member of public or anyone in
this state it's amazing how little
it happens yeah but we used to put mps
in that scenario
particularly mps that are critical or or
had who didn't understand the process
and it and
after an hour or so they'd come back
with a different view
yeah they have difficulty we can put the
darkness down now we can have several
people coming out you're gonna have
someone behind you
these are the things you're gonna have
to consider you're gonna shoot that
person you're gonna shoot the person
behind you
what's that is that are they giving up
or are they shooting you what are they
doing are they shooting your mate
what are you going to do you know those
so
so the selection particularly for police
officers
in those those areas is is intense
and and and those things are still
pulled apart
it's very difficult it's very difficult
the actual
um the scenario of placing an actual
place in it is is
very very difficult particularly now
when you've got body camera and every
decision every word that you say
is going to be pulled apart by in the
calmness of the court
by several different people by the media
you'll have to your trial and media
first of all
and then maybe go to court but already
the
the public have made a decision or
whoever has put that edited that bit of
film has made their decision so it's
very difficult
it's very very difficult job but those
right alongs are so important because
i've seen a few videos of that type
where you have to make the split second
decision it changes your view of it
completely
it says very difficult scenario you know
there are there are small minority of
police officers who are armed
still one of the few armed unarmed
police forces in the world
you know and we're talking about you
know europe as well you know
we consider ourselves kind of european
and you know
or maybe closer to america they're all
armed we're still
walking around without arms yeah and
i don't know what what their answer is
to that but uh i think probably more
officers who are armed is better well
you you were you were a firearms officer
for a while
this is what one of the things i wanted
to talk to you about in terms of
the public complete lack of
understanding of the job that you guys
do because
we talked about this before we started
about the london bridge bomber
and i remember on the day someone on
twitter going
oh why couldn't they just like uh you
know shoot him in the leg yeah
yeah and you're good do you have any
idea what you're talking about i blame
american films for that
because i i don't i don't and i know and
i'll tell you
the implication of that um we introduced
um a laser kind of on a taser
yeah um and it was a red light even
before that we just had a red light and
it was a taser
and we used to have people fall into the
floor when the red light hit them
there was no gun of writing attached to
it or anything just a red light and
they'd hit the floor
because they thought well they've seen
the films red light hits you you're
going to be shot that's it here the
floor
because american films tell people you
can wing people as they're running away
when they've got a gun
in their hand you you you're taught to
it hits this between the torso because
that will disable them there's more
likely
to disable them stop them doing you're
not sure you don't shoot to kill you
shoot to stop them doing whatever
they're doing
right this is really good chris you
break it down for people who don't
understand firearms you don't understand
biology
right why do you have to shoot someone
here to the same right but that's the
most like that's the most
that area has the virtual organs in it's
going to be
the most likely to stop them doing what
they're going to do
or what they're about to do shooting a
weapon at you
or someone else yeah and why can't you
if you shot a gun
exactly it's a moving target it's very
small you're less likely to hit that
target yeah you've only got a brief few
seconds or a
micro segment to to stop that person
shooting you or suiting someone else
that body part is the the area you're
going to have most success
yes okay so shooting on a leg you can
still
people have been shot in the leg you can
still that before that kicks in and
maybe you bleed to death or you you can
still carry the weapon and
shoot them with uh suicide bombers
um you you've got a very small it's a
very risky tactic because
they could have a trigger that releases
and sets off or if they press
sets off you don't know what that is and
and ideally you're not going to be
anywhere near them but bring your close
up like
the boys and girls on on the on the
bridge they have dealt with someone who
was presenting
himself as a suicide bomber and people
thought oh well it's very cool what they
did obviously it's been the inquest has
gone and
that's decided it was a tactic that was
it was
suitable but he already told them he was
a suicidal he wanted to die
and this is another issue death by cop
when
in as far as we had people who really
wanted to die
and they wanted you to take them with
him and they would do everything to
provoke you into that
obviously quite often you'd use
non-lethal weapon
uh a taser or a baton round or something
to disable them and then so you can
arrest them because you don't want to
kill people
you don't go into the place to kill
people you know so
and and all and and so quite often
you're presented someone like a suicide
bomber
probably wants to die yeah and they and
even though it turned out to be a fake
fest
how do you know no you don't how do you
know that's a fake verse you're
presented with
so yeah i think there was a minority of
people who said oh well it's very cool
what they did but when they actually
realized
the scenario where there's a suicide
bomber when that guy
when you can see the farmers often
realize he's got a vest on
and he shouts to his colleagues standing
back you know and he's got he's got to
take that shot
uh if it was a suicide bomb all the
people have been dead you know
having the passers-by everyone would
have been dead i mean as we've seen in
israel and places there
that suicide bombers are used often
you know a lot of people can be taken
out with that they were very brave
and chris do is there i mean this is a
very broad question
but do you ever see the the criminals
who come in who get arrested
is there ever a common theme with them
like you know do they come from a
certain background
or not really oh
no not really i would say i worked i've
worked in
covent garden uh one of my first one was
covered garden boaster
rich city kids uh pissed or
coked up um to you know tottenham with
people with uh
poor or poorer backgrounds and there is
no real
common theme i'm sure if you dig into it
you
you would find some kind of common thing
but i've seen criminals from
the wide spectrum uh all you know
quite often um fighting you or whatever
particularly
the city boys when we were in the common
garden you know
i remember two guys through another
pub goer out the plate gas window boat
and sat down and drank their pines
afterwards
you know um so yeah we've seen all kinds
but it comes from all kinds of
backgrounds i don't know if
it's i'm sure this you know people would
dig into it and find there's a there's a
theme somewhere along the line but i
haven't seen it
and i don't know if you'd have any
strong views in which and if you don't
we don't
really need to get into it but what do
you make because
obviously a lot of the of the crime is
in relation to drugs
right do you think our policy on drugs
as a country is is the right approach do
you think we need
to slacken the laws on that and let
people you know smoke weed without being
punished or do you think on we need to
make
harsher laws like what's i think i think
they've watered down quite a bit
over the years i think we you know we
used to rest people for
a small part a small bit of uh cannabis
yeah uh and and they'd go for the system
total waste of time in my view yeah um
and now i thought you get a warning for
for possession of a small possession of
cannabis i think that the system is
already
you know uh going down that way uh
to to um you know lesson personal use
you're very unlikely first time to be a
prison sentence or
this criminal justice system has already
adjusted itself and it's still adjusting
itself and it's not for the police
officers to make that decision
it's for the society as a whole to
decide
yeah okay people are i don't think they
the crime is
often not caused yeah they to feed their
habit
sometimes heroin and maybe coke but
um to find drugs in the system of
someone who's committed crime is a bit
misleading i think
because you know people of all walks of
life take drugs
so uh i think this criminal justice
system certainly when i started in 83 to
now
has already adjusted itself to the
acceptance of
a small amount of drugs or the small use
of personal using drugs i guess what i'm
getting at is do you think
uh you might benefit as a police force
from taking some of the resources that
are targets that are dealing with people
using drugs or whatever
and and directing it more towards people
that are you know committing violent
crime or whatever well yeah
and it's difficult to gauge we're we're
to start there yeah
the the big deal is the person who's
who's
using or or needs to to
to commit crime to feed that use you
don't know it's very complex
yeah it's very it's very complex yes
definitely use the the
money should be put into the because
it's a much wider spread
issue than people like to admit i think
in the in the world in
certainly in the country you know and
and and a lot of people just get on with
it and their life and continued and
they're without any effect but there are
a
lot
some people who do um suffer badly and
it affects their lives but yes
absolutely that's a common it's a fact
of life
drugs and and resources should be put
into into
helping people who i definitely feel
that and one of the things that is
connected with drugs is obviously the
gangs are going to supply them county
lines
do you think in particular in london the
gang problem has got worse
because you started in 83 or is it
mainly maintained consistent do you
think i think
gangs have just changed it's not gangs
you know
gangs i i i was walking down um
as a probationer you used to have to
walk alone you so you do your first two
years mainly walking alone
and i remember walking into gerard
street and common garden and i got
held from behind someone grabbed me from
behind and held me
i remember how hard it was it was real
and they chopped someone up right in
front of me
um with an ice pick um anyway
and then it went off um and i remember
dealing with that the individual and
then
and then people come in and dealing with
them and then we asked for
for uh witnesses no one saw a thing
there were people sat there
there and stood there with blood on them
who didn't see a thing
and when we realized it was 14k in the
museum well
um triad gangs in who they had a
vice-like grip
on people they were gangs then there
were there were vicious gangs there
there in vietnamese gangs
there were all kinds again gangs have
always existed i mean gangs of london
there's this program it goes back
to you know the gangs have always
existed in some form the teddy boys are
not so much gangs there were a group of
social
you know whatever they call them but
there's always been gangs a group of
people who have a common purpose
to make more money for themselves
whatever doing whatever criminality
generally
you know so no i don't think it's a new
thing gangs but
but in the context of like you know the
particularly young
young boys getting involved so i used to
be a teacher yeah in you and for 12
years
yeah and i saw children that i taught i
was a primary school teacher i saw 10
and 11 year old boys getting involved in
it
and also i remember like a former pupil
of mine
who came back to see me and i was
talking to him and i was saying
well you know you've been excited from
this one secondary school but you've got
a chance of
going to this new one yeah how do you
feel about that he goes i can't go there
and i won't why not he went because
they'll murder me
yeah and yeah i mean that that seems to
be more overt
now um but
i mean there are there is peer pressure
and
quite often when you look at those gangs
because i've dealt with i
i don't i used to help out oh in fact i
was a
member of the committee at the bottom
academy in in hackney in tottenham
and dealt with kids have been uh pushed
out of the the the schooling system or
can't be handled in the schooling system
and they were in gangs and it was and if
you push beyond that it was the family
background that really
uh this was their family the black the
gang was their family
yeah and they come from really sad often
sad backgrounds
where the subfamily unit wasn't as
strong and
that was a common theme between gangs
and maybe that's become more prevalent i
don't know
um you know the family unit has been
maybe replaced in some people's eyes and
lives by the gang
and that's dangerous and that's sad as
well but it's all about belonging isn't
it
if you don't belong to your family who
do you belong to and if those group
that group of people make you feel loved
in a way
um then that's what you're going to be
drawn towards
yeah you know one of the things that a
lot of our viewers have been just moving
on now a little bit i've been asking
about is we've
we obviously had the blm protest earlier
in the year which uh in which
quite a few police officers were injured
if i remember and equally
it felt like he was quite laggedly
policed you know at least that was the
perception
for many people you sort of winsted that
yeah
yeah i i just know how difficult it is
to do those those demons i've been
in public you know when you see these
things on twitter like a police officer
kneeling you know it's not a good look
that was a mistake
yeah that was a mistake i i i didn't
agree with that i think
and i'll tell you why i didn't agree
with it you don't get involved in
politics straight away
first of all that's one of the things
you know don't get involved in policies
now how good that cause will be i'm
actually you believe that calls
you're there to maintain peace the
queen's piece as they say but you're
there to maintain
their right to demonstrate and people's
rights to go about their normal business
don't get involved in whatever political
and i think that was a mistake and
probably in hindsight they wouldn't have
done that because it actually provokes
more violence in the end
yeah but uh going back to emphasize that
point where i stood outside
in 1984 1985 stood outside the south
african embassy
in trafalgar square and people going how
can you defend
the south african embassy went in the
height of apartheid he used to give me
awful hell standing out there you know
all from you know they were all
so-called people who abhorred racism but
they selected me for my race
yeah so they would go on about me so
i wasn't defending i had no problem even
then i'm defending the right
to for the these people to demonstrate
and people to go back to normal is when
people get it for the governments to
decide whether the
south african embassy should be and in
the end it obviously collapsed apartheid
which obviously i'd heard
but if i took if you turned up to your
parade with 44 people
and said right okay do you believe in
this course anyone like willing to
police this one
uh no i don't know what i think i'd
rather
you know to be fair sri lanka should be
independent in that way
you know you could you wouldn't have
that you'd get nowhere
yeah your job is to maintain peace right
and people say oh well you know
you just you you know you sign off for
the devil you
you know it's not your job to to to
take sides or decide whether they i've
been on
far-right marches i've been on far left
masters i've been on all kinds of
artists and quite often for my to make
my day go i'd always speak to them no
matter what even if they hated me
yeah i'd speak to them i'd ask them what
their course was because it makes it a
much easier day
um a much more interesting they but
don't get involved
in whether they should be there or not
or whether
you want to stop them being there and
the perception obviously
from that that is when we were in
lockdown and two
how did it be how was it let's develop
now i'm pretty sure the people who made
that decision made it with a heavy heart
or or
they would rather have no one been there
because that was the law actually you
know we weren't allowed to gather in
right
and that started before blm though it
started with a remember the service
which is a good cause yeah but people
started gathering large groups in public
against the law
yeah yes it was a good cause but
people are saying well hold on a minute
if you can do that and as you've seen in
public officials people take a lead
don't they oh if they can get away with
that i'm gonna do it and then it kind of
has a knock on effect
but as far as the back line i don't
think it was softly softly it did look
like
in sometimes it was softly softly but
i'm sure the pcs
or the the senior management probably
all the management on the ground
didn't mean it to to look like that way
at all
i guess what i and check your point
completely completely accept that
what i'm talking about is we saw the way
that was policed yes
however you would describe that we did
see a bit of the kneeling and
which you don't agree with but equally
we've just had protests a few weeks ago
which is people protesting against
lockdown yeah and
i i wasn't there i don't know if you
were none of us were there
but it suddenly looked like a very
different approach for the police
well the approach in lockdown has
developed isn't it
yeah throughout you know what we did in
the start what we do now is totally
different
um we've seen the effects of letting
people
break the law openly and how that has an
effect of knock-on effect and maybe
they've decided now that
this is not this is not something you
need that needs to be broadcast people
standing by letting people break the law
which is you know no matter how good a
cause it is
yeah or what or what they think is um
so maybe the senior officers i don't
know what in their mind i've decided
well maybe we know we need to
show the public that breaking the law
isn't acceptable
even if you think it's a good cause so
you think it's more like they've evolved
i think it's involved i think it's
graduated their
their response has graduated throughout
the time obviously people have
other ideas oh well it was white people
were just obviously
policed a lot more harshly than black
people that's what the public
without even making a racial it's just
like there was a double standard there
that
it certainly appeared though you have
it's not double standard you have to
take the intelligence
uh the dynamics the the environment
all these things into place when you
police a demonstration
you know i've been on some very pleasant
demonstrations i've been on one was huge
with sri lankan the sri lankan
demonstration when they took
over the whole of parliament square uh
like unbelievable they just
they came from nowhere and all of a
sudden on a whistle motor there
but they gave us nice food it was great
so it was it was very peaceful yeah and
and and i've also been like
you should have been a police officer
yeah i've also been on a
i remember the anti-capitalist march
when we first used kesley
i mean outside the bank of england and i
remember the the
the for me it wasn't the museum because
there was some so i think tomlinson was
it was
not on that particular day but for me
that the first day before that happened
the amusing thing was how the chief at
the end of six seven hours said right
i'd declare this this gathering to be
finished
and everyone went home but that was
supposed to be anarchists so i don't
know how that happened
so uh it was you please each individual
um uh public gathering or demonstration
with the intelligence that you got and
the resources you got and the
environment they're in
it all takes the factors and how you
place that
that individual it may look softly soft
in one way but it may be that they've
got other
different intelligence and chris there
was something that i particularly wanted
to talk to you about and this was an
incident that happened a year and a half
ago my parents were burgled
my and my they actually interrupted the
burglary
the people fled my parents are in their
70s they're very old very thrilled
and then they called up the police and
then within one hour the case was closed
they were given a crime reference number
and they went nothing more can be done
just to be clear this is not just about
his parents
i've had the same thing car broken i
know we we get a lot of our viewers
saying things like that yes you know
well it's priorities you have to
prioritize your resources and the
resources the police resources
are limited yeah so
for instance you know that i don't know
there's specifics yeah
um and that must be horrifying i i know
i know
um how the effect it has on on
particularly older people is
and it's terrible and when we were
driven for figures when we actually used
to go to every scene
of burglary and sit with people we used
to be have resp
we used to be required to do it within a
certain time and that wasn't possible
because
impact on victims are different and
sometimes you have to spend time you
have to have a cup of tea with them
you've got to get the scenes of crime
off so you've got to get the
the builder to go and do their windows
sometimes you have to be there for hours
but that the the demand on your
resources uh doesn't
allow you to do that and they've you
know in some cases they've decided that
you know
a burglary where the the suspect is no
longer there
has to be reported reported over the
phone
and um and sadly it means sometimes that
a officer doesn't attend that scene and
it sounds like that's what happened
do you agree with that oh god no
obviously i don't agree with it i'd like
to everyone to get a bespoke
um yeah of course i would i wouldn't
it's frustrating as a manager of a
relief that i had you know
that you can't go to these things police
officers want to deal with victims
that's the most i say this most
effective way
no one's screaming and shouting you
actually have a real effect you know you
you know you're doing good
when you sit could they'd love to sit
with every victim of crime
and and have a cup of tea and make sure
they're all right and get them
the appropriate support and they'd love
to do that and
you know it's just frustrating for most
police officers that you can't
how badly underfunded is the police so
badly underfunded it's been run down
it's been run down since the austerity
austerity drive you know
uh and it's come to a point where you
you can't
have all these expectations on the
police and not fund them you know
and some of the people who are most
loudest about we need this we know are
the ones that cut in your legs you know
almost like
you know douglas howe said you know
you're breaking the captain's the
batsman's
bat before you go out you know you're
actually expecting them to get 100 and
you've broken their back
you know so no it's very frustrating and
they have
been run down to dangerous levels do you
think we've been lied to about that in
the sense that
that people i think some people are
trying to claim that you can defund
not defund the police but you can reduce
funding cut number of frontline officers
and yeah crime's going to be fine no is
that how it works
no it doesn't work like that at all from
your experience if
there was enough resources a police
officer would have spent time with your
parents
you know made sure that was that it was
okay and that would have had a positive
effect on you and your family
that's one direct result of defunding
you know
so you can have more instances like that
um
that you've only got a certain amount of
people to deal with
a lot of crime but particularly you know
domestic violence particularly you know
you you deal with an awful lot of
domestic violence
um you have to spend time with them
because that victim sometimes
you you look at that victim and they're
saying no i don't want to press the
crime i don't want to press charges and
they're really screaming
please get this man out of my house you
know and and
that takes time you know you can't walk
away from that you can't do that over
the phone
so you have to prioritize different
crimes you know with the
with the limited resources that you've
got and it's very frustrating for
managers
very frustrating i mean how badly
underfunded
the police services you said it was
dangerous could you give us some
examples of
well it was like your example you have
but you've go into those officers who
are
policing black lives matter they're
policing
you know anti-lock down process every
one of them could be reporting
dealing with a victim of crime on their
own burrows they're all just boris
it's not a magic box of riots trained
officers who are going to go
they're often pulled away from locals
local citizens and the more of those
that go on
the less resources there are to deal
with burglaries and robberies and
and domestic violence victims and rape
victims on a local basis
so it's totally responsible on both sets
and i don't agree with either of them
you know
it's totally responsible they're
dragging away resources and then they'll
be kind crying that police officer never
turned up
to a robbery or or the fact that you
know someone
someone's been beaten up by the husband
and someone's called and it took 10
minutes 15 minutes for them to get there
because there's no one
you know that's where it comes from it's
in there's a
it's not a uh endless box of police
officers there's a
limited resource um that is getting
well they're trying to expand it at the
moment but we've
what we've been hit our economy is being
hit now
when's that going to happen i don't know
who knows and
what effect has lockdown had on the
police what challenges have they faced
there are some positive effects locked
down in particular because there's not
many
there's not as many people getting
burgled for instance because everyone's
at home
there's not as many people getting
robbed because not as many people out on
the street
well not the last lockdown because i see
a lot of people on the street but
those things so you can move the
resources then yeah
lockdown is actually not too bad for the
police because
it means that a lot of crimes go down in
a lot of ways i speak to
regular officers regularly and they say
yeah well that that you know burglaries
have gone down
robberies have gone down you know car
theft's gone down but they you know
that means they're freeing up but we
can't spend our lives locked in can we
really that's not an ideal that's not
ideal
um and the police don't want it either
chris thank you so much for coming on
the show it's been an absolute pleasure
and well actually before we you're
winding up the beginning but before we
ask your last question uh
i wanted to ask you i think a lot of
people and i include myself on this
there's bits of policing maybe i
understand because like firearms is
something i've always been interested in
you know i've shot guns play a lot of
computer games or whatever right
so i have an idea i've done some
research but there's lots of other
things i completely don't understand and
i think
the public on many issues are also like
that on many things
so what do you think people don't know
or misunderstand about what
being a police officer is like or what
why police do certain things that they
do
is there a thing that you wish would you
if you could get across to everybody in
the country
that they don't know what would it be
well they're just representatives of
of of you you know they're just your son
your daughter
doing trying to do a job yeah they're
not they don't go to work to try
and uh victimize people so that they can
make their lives harder they don't go to
work to shoot people so that they can be
involved in endless inquiry inquests and
make their
their lives horrible they do go to work
just
generally to you know to get through the
day to help as many people as they
possibly can and to come home and earn a
living
but if i would say i would say anything
to the members of public
is take what politicians say with a huge
pinch of salt
yeah because they don't often tell you
the truth and one more question
something we had uh
the conservative comments it's very
colombo of you by the way just one more
question just one more question
but we had uh peter hitchens on the show
i don't know yeah and he
he's quite critical of the fact that uh
police
no longer do as much beat policing as
they used to yeah
uh you you can't you're just running
you're fire fighting you haven't got
you're not time to be walking around um
you know
talking about in them old days you could
do it but there wasn't
there wasn't performance indicators then
there wasn't it wasn't limited but there
wasn't the huge amount of crime reported
over the phone
and computers that's all accelerated and
multiplied crime reporting
you had time to walk from street to
street and you know where harry's going
to click round here i'll get into his
mouth
you ain't got time for that you're just
fire fighting an awful lot they're going
from one call to another i know
i've managed these teams yeah they're
just going from one call to another they
haven't got time
sadly they'd love to oh if you said to a
police officer please
stay in this road today and have a cup
of tea with everyone on this road
they'd love it you know they would love
it but they haven't got time to do it
sadly
because of the resources are so
restricted and
second time around so what is the one
thing that we're not talking about as a
society but we really should be
ah well we talked we're not talking i
think
i think i think the thing that we're not
talking about is the fact that
black parents and the black community
have as much
vested interest in the police as the
white community we're all it's all as
is important to all of us every color
that we have a vibrant and
useful police force that we back no one
wants to be a victim of crime no
of any color and and and it always
if you look at the media it's as if
every black person thinks the police are
the enemy and it and they don't
i know they don't it's
disproportionately represented in the
place in the in the media i think
that makes a lot of sense we do see a
lot of that don't we yeah yeah
chris listen it's been absolutely
brilliant thank you so much for coming
on if people want to follow
you know you put your thoughts out on
twitter every now and again where would
you like people to go to
keep in touch with you well yeah
children 1963 on twitter
is my uh it's my handle so yeah if they
want to
abuse me or please feel free
i'm used to it no i think our your
message actually will resonate with a
lot of people who watch the show and
they'll appreciate you coming on as well
as donald trump
i've enjoyed it thank you very much for
everything thank you for coming and
thank you for watching we will see you
very soon with another episode like this
one
uh or a live stream all of them go out
7pm uk time take care and see you soon
guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word